if
mike pence is the lead for republicans
you know who would you put second third
do you think
trump has a chance of running again in
2024 the best thing is for
him to just sit this one out and say
look you've done your part your one-term
president
let somebody else come in what do you
think is going to happen with trump
well i'm not jewish so i don't have the
gift of prophecy
so but look my sense is
uh the the damage that was done on the
sixth and and the damage that's being
done right now
on on capitol hill in the in the united
states senate
and the damage that they've got they're
going to try to destroy this man
okay they're going to bring lawsuits
against every one of his hotels
all of his golf courses there's going to
be an inquisition the likes of which
none of us can imagine i've been through
a little bit of that back in the 80s
there's going to be senate
investigations there's going to be house
investigations there's going to be
criminal charges brought by probably a
dozen or more
u.s attorneys what it's going to do is
try to they're going to try to ruin him
right and so given that reality and
given the fact that he's got a bunch of
kids of his own and a bunch of grandkids
he would be wise i think to focus on
that
to encourage others to get into involved
in i don't think he got to give up
a leadership role but i think what needs
to happen right now is he needs to
protect himself and his family he needs
around i hate to say this and don't tell
anybody i have a son who's a lawyer
so don't put that out there but he needs
some really good lawyers around him and
he's not had a bunch of them yet
yeah i mean it's it's uh i mean if if
you're saying not a bunch of them you're
putting giuliani is not a good lawyer
if you're saying that but i i don't
think that's what you're saying
was a great mayor wow okay fair i mean
if that's what you that's a pretty
direct
call out right there so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye-bye
you